thanks for tuning in today to this
special edition of Google developers
live today we have Joshua and Courtney
Woodward joining us as the GDG Fresno
high organizers and later we'll have
some of the students numbers of GE
fresno high joining us in celebration of
computer science education week i am van
riper i work with our google developer
groups around the world as their
community advocate and I've worked with
Josh for a long time as one of our Gigi
Fresno organizers and today Josh and
Courtney are going to tell us about how
they got started with jejeje or fresno
high that's correct man being a part of
GDG Fresno we were involved with adults
and already established programmers and
we wanted to get high schoolers involved
and my wife is a teacher at a local high
school fresno high and so I approached
her and asked how do we start a club and
get kids involved and how can I come on
campus and teach kids how to code
accorded you were saying how that the
beginning out you know the challenges
you had to start with well absolutely
because to be a club sponsor that's
above and beyond your teaching
responsibilities your classroom
responsibilities so a lot is on your own
time coordinating with other adults on
campus to get the club started to get a
meeting place and in this case one of
our greatest obstacles was getting
computers in front of the kids so they
can actually code and then you told me
how this year has really taken off you
did the club Expo at the beginning of
the year and right so um since it was
new and there was no sort of tech club
on campus it we didn't know where to
start and at the middle of last year we
said well we're just going to go for it
so we got the paperwork in and recruited
a few kids but there it was really hard
to get the word out and we didn't have
computers this year however at the
beginning of the air we did the club
Expo I had Josh's google glass on that
really caught kids attention and
had over 60 students sign up that were
interested in some sort of aspect of
Technology or computer science or just
learning more about Google products and
how often do the students meet now we
meet once a week on average about once a
week during lunch or after school in a
computer lab where we have access to
computers we started off just by showing
them like the video on co.org and you
know they get really inspired when they
hear like free food and they get to play
pool all day so like that got them
hooked into the club but now we do
actual hands-on stuff so like we built a
tic-tac-toe game in JavaScript and walk
through through that step by step on
what everything that's going on that's
great and you also told me that you did
something kind of unique I think you
might one of the first well you are the
first high school group that we've ever
had we've had many University chapters
but GG fresno high as our first chapter
within a high school but you were able
to get a google apps for business for
education for the yeah so we have a we
have a domain fresno high warriors calm
and it has a google apps for education
account tied to it so somewhere in the
requirement that just said you had to be
a school organization and so that's what
we were so now the students get their
name at fresno high warriors calm and
they have access to google drive
accounts and google docs and we can
actually open up a doc and plan a
meeting and share and how much did that
cost that's free that's right it's free
so at the schools out there if you want
to start a chapter like this at your
high school if you work with an
organizer like josh in your area because
we don't allow under 18 people to
organize groups but if you get an adult
organizer in your high school you could
produce presley get these google apps
for education for your students as well
which is great that's the great thing
you guys did yeah that's one of the
things is why it worked i think is
because my wife was a teacher on campus
so it was easy to get in that way on
campus so it's just a matter of
getting somebody that's on campus so if
you're a teacher on campus and you want
to start a club go to the Google
developers group directory and see if
there's a chapter in your area and
contact that organizer and work with
them probably yeah greatest so maybe now
we should actually talk to some of the
students about their experience with the
group's sound good yep and we're back
with Fresno high school students Chris
Marshawn and Riley so Chris tell us
about how you got started coding oh well
i was really bored for about a month
during summer and my grandma was reading
the newspaper and she saw this thing
called 59 days of code and it was
downtown in my city and she took me down
there and there was a man named jake
sober all and he is starting a new
course and he teaches kids had a code
because he says that there's not enough
people that are coding that needs to be
much more back to you then make your
Chris so how about you Marshawn how did
you get started I got started coming by
like when I was little I used to always
make our own mess around talking analogy
you know you know how little kids are
I'd like to do different things don't
know which one to pick so you know like
when I got the professional high you
know I used to go to a library like
everyday doing lunch after school
sometime sometime before school and I
never heard of the GDG program that mrs.
Woodward had gone she found me so I was
like yeah I joined so the first day was
on Thursday I went it was like a variety
of different kids I was like I probably
can fit in because ain't just for like
what kind of kid no pigs alone you just
football players basketball players
anybody so that's right
that's great Marshawn so how about you
Riley how did you get started um well I
my stepdad Josh started me on Codecademy
on like online and I played around with
that for a little while and then sort of
lost interest in it seemed a little bit
out of my league like it seemed I'd so
far to go and kind of discouraged me a
little bit but when the club started it
actually like it helped me realize how
like I could find my place and like do
things at my level I didn't have to be a
master at anything I could just work at
with what I had and it would be enough
so it really encouraged me to do more so
great so what keeps you coming back to
GEG Fresno hi um I just really like
coding and I like my teacher that
teaches that and I don't know i think
the kids are really nice and it's all
it's really like good in there everybody
can fit in hey how about you Riley well
um it's like the next big thing it is
the big thing and it will be for some
time I think like it's computers and
Google and developing and it's not gonna
be out of style or something like next
year it'll be around and it'll keep
growing and keep getting better and I'd
like to be part of that great about you
Marcia our other competitors gonna be
around for was like it isn't a new thing
like you can see so now that you're
gonna say everybody with the computer
you can see everybody do to doing the
coding it's like I like to have my
sphere everybody around me is like smart
intelligent bright I like them so do any
of you have any final thoughts I think
like actually speak to your peers out
their students may be other schools like
like why you think they should get
involved in something like this yeah I
think everybody should be a part of
coding because it's going to be like the
future like I think everybody's going to
code mostly like you should do this
it's available I'm gonna say like try
something new for for chance you know
like don't keep doing the same thing
over and over cuz when I today's gonna
be a boring right so yeah sort of along
the same lines even if you think it's
like too hard or you have a long way to
go you just keep working at it and even
though you're a beginner you can still
contribute in some way to either your
community here to some project so just
don't get discouraged about it well
that's great well I appreciate really
appreciate your time Chris Marshall and
rally for coming out and telling us
about your experiences and I'd also like
to thank Joshua and Courtney Woodward as
well as the fresno high school for their
support in this first-ever GDG google
developer group chapter four in high
school as you can see from the
discussion today you know students
really warm to this they really are
passionate about learning about
technology and we really like to see
many more groups like this be inspired
by what we heard about today and you can
participate by going to CS Edwin org and
joining in an hour of code during
computer science education week